hace una semana este cementerio era
probablemente un cuarto de lo que es
ahora mismo nos encontramos en el pueblo
de chequero va en la provincia de
carnaval maras el epicentro del
terremoto que ocurrió el lunes por la
madrugada y la escena aquí es de puro
caos y desesperación como pueden
observar el cementerio está lleno de
nuevas
tumbas en lugares donde reposan a las
personas muertas de esta localidad nos
cuentan los locales Que en total han
muerto en este pueblo de 11.000 personas
unas 800 personas el caos está grande
dentro del pueblo que nos explican ellos
mismos que la policía no levanta los
cadáveres en los propios vecinos los que
después de recibir las bolsas para
levantar los cadáveres de la ayuda que
les llega a cuentagotas son ellos mismos
los que tienen que meter los cadáveres
de sus familiares dentro de sus propios
coches y venir aquí
y enterrarlos directamente nos contaba
un vecino del lugar que en las últimas
horas han llegado bastantes familias Hoy
es el primer día aseguraba que no hay
muchísima gente en ese cementerio en el
que sin embargo acabará llegando más
gente porque en este pueblo aún Hay
personas debajo de los escombros cuentan
ya aquí con las temperaturas por la
noche a varios grados bajo cero nadie
considera ya que esas personas que
siguen en estos edificios atrapados
estén con vida por lo tanto las
actividades de rescate aquí no han
parado siguen pero lo hacen de una forma
muy distinta a la adrenalina y al
intento desesperado de sacar las
personas que ocurrían sobre todo durante
los primeras horas y los primeros días